welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we're gonna be breaking down the new
imagining of Hansel and Gretel Gretel
and Hansel switches up the original grim
fairy tale in several ways beyond just
the name and throughout this video we'll
be discussing the overall plot and its
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to see
the movie yet and don't want anything
ruin it then I highly recommend that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day
and without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of Gretel
and Hansel Gretel and Hansel opens with
its own sort of fairy tale centered
around the beautiful child with the
little pink cap this introduction tells
the story of a young baby that falls
terribly ill and in order to save it her
father resorts to taking the child to a
witch the Witch manages to get rid of
the illness but as a trade-off it places
a dog power within her lair in the film
growl discusses how there is nothing
good without something being taken away
and this is exemplified early on in the
opening the entire movie is about how if
something sounds too good to be true
it often is and this is murdered in the
amazing food roof over their head and
the shelter that they get later on in
the film I'm skipping ahead here though
but as the young girl grows she becomes
a profit providing premonitions of the
future to the villagers however they
begin to dislike her as everyone's life
ends in death but we don't really want
to be told this as she grew older the
girl began bringing these prophesized
deaths to reality and started slowly
killing the villagers including her own
father left with little option she was
taken into the woods and abandoned there
the child would grow up to become
someone that is central to the storyline
later and I'll get into this further in
the video Orion pictures aren't really
known for highbrow horror but this feels
up there stylistically with the likes of
an A 24 movie and that's because of
their high quality back catalogue and
yeah where we've had things like The
Grudge already it shows that you don't
need to pack films with
scares in order for them to have a
sinister vibe I loved that the film
carries the message there is always a
catch and I'm sure in the end that the
parents of the girl would have rather
had the illness than what eventually
ended up happening to her and them we
jump forward a number of years and learn
that a which has been luring children
into the woods and this is when we step
into the shoes of Gretel and her younger
brother Hansel Gretel is sent out to
find work as a housekeeper but after her
potential employer asks if she's a
virgin it becomes clear what his
intentions are angered by her refusal to
do whatever she can to get a job
grellus mother kicks her and a younger
brother out of the house and they slowly
make their way into the woods to fend
for themselves now I'll get one of my
major criticisms out of the way first
and that is that Sophia Lillis does a
poor job at masking her American accent
whilst this wouldn't be a problem in a
film where everyone had a similar sort
of dialect here where the majority of
the cast sound British it does stick out
like a sore thumb I don't know if I'm
just picking up on that because I'm
British but she does a great job with
the material bar that it is just a
nitpick and the girl can clearly act and
she pretty much carries the entire film
on her shoulders so I don't want to be
too harsh but I thought I'd just get
that out here so I can talk about the
film in a more positive light as we go
on when making their own way in the
world they come across a hunter who
rescues the siblings from a ghoul and
later some magic mushrooms that cause
the two to hallucinate starving and with
a little chance of survival it seems
like almost a miracle when they stumble
across a house filled to the brim with
food this belongs to a witch who offers
them a place to stay in exchange for
work now on the whole the film does
follow the framework of the source
material however it also differs in some
unique ways this is mainly in Gretel who
we learn in the film has the powers of a
witch herself she can make things
levitate and move has second sight and
slowly she refines her abilities
throughout the movie there's lip service
paid to the chosen one and it's also at
this point that both she and Hansel
start to see visions of an enchantress
in the witch holder's cellar Gretel
finds her brother and also discovers The
Enchantress who has been transforming
lost children into the food that the two
eating she realizes that holder has been
fattening Hansel up to feed on him and
that she is grooming Gretel to become
her apprentice when holder casts a spell
her fingers turn black and this plays
massively into the ending of the film
initially Gretel tries to play ignorant
to the entire thing but she can't bear
it and after seeing holder pull a long
strand of hair over mouth she begs the
witch to let her brother go holder comes
with a warning that Hansel will
eventually end a painting Gretel because
men basically fear women with power and
this conversation sort of shapes the way
that things transpire in the film
towards the end it's here that we get a
big bombshell in the movie and holder
explains to Gretel that the story we saw
in the beginning is tied directly to her
we actually learn that holder was the
young girl's mother from the opening and
that she hated her daughter after she
killed her father and she's the one that
took the child into the woods
however the girl remained in holders
mind and stalked her from afar she
promised to share her abilities with
holder but this came at a great cost
greedy and lustful for power wishing to
be forever young holder decided to work
with a daughter and she ate her children
and then began luring others like lambs
to the slaughter
we know from earlier that there is
nothing good without something being
taken away and this stands strong as a
testament to the journey that holder
went on whole that can transform back
and forth from being young and old and
predominantly she takes the latter form
in order to seem kind in weak this
allows children to trust her and she
pretty much wants Gretel to follow in
her footsteps becoming the chosen one an
apprentice of sorts and to prove that
she's all in on the cause although once
said to eat her brother this is the
ultimate sacrifice and it's something
that she had to perform a self on the
ones that she loved the most in order to
truly unleash your own power she
transforms into a younger self the witch
that we saw earlier and after putting
the boy in a trance sends him to be
cooked left with no other option Gretel
manifests her powers and sends holders
staff flying towards the character
pinning her to the oven wall and slowly
burning her alive she eventually pushes
it through until it behead sir and her
body burns in the fire ending her
control over the boy this breaks the
trance on Hansel and he awakens the next
day right
Rane realizing that the witch was right
and that the two will only get in the
way of one another she charms a horse
and sends Hansel home with riches
Hansel goes back to his house and finds
an axe there and his mother gone
now this teases a lot of things and also
could add some hints as to what's really
going on with their mother there are two
ways you can look at it either someone
broke into the house killed her or she
was actually a manifestation of whole
there and after a death the character
disappeared to Gretel clearly had witch
blood in her and it is possible a holder
set this entire thing to manipulate her
into hating the world due to what it did
to her and this would drive her to the
dark side where where have I heard this
before anyway that's just one theory and
she could have herself been denounced as
a witch as we know she has witch blood
in her and a hunter could have arrived
and killed her as was common during the
time Hansel picks up the axe and this
sets up that the character could become
a hunter himself throughout the film we
did see him slowly getting better at
using an axe and he honed his abilities
as did Gretel Gretel stays at the house
and we see her fingers turn black
similar to how hold us did she vows to
do good and has a choice to either stay
and build something positive or go and
never look back though we don't know
which side she chooses personally I
think we can assume that she ends up
firmly rooted at the property as
mentioned throughout this video if we
want something good then something must
be taken away and I viewed her sending
Hansel off home as being this trade-off
with the witch gone the souls of the
children she feasted upon are now free
to journey into the afterlife growl once
seized the spellbook of the witch to
bring life back to the forest and though
she believes she is the chosen one it is
for good rather than darkness the film
ends on a hopeful note with both
children using experience to go off into
the woods and we cut the credits known
that they become better for the ordeal
that they've just been through there's
also a theory that the two are just
unmatched mushrooms hallucinating this
entire thing and slowly dying in the
woods together which yeah
not very happy anywhere what did I think
of the movie overall well though I did
mention a couple of problems earlier in
the video I had a lot of fun with the
film and it's one of the most unique
Horrors that I've seen in a while up
there with the lighthouse in terms of
i allistic choices the movie elevates
itself above a lot of other films in the
genre
due to its cinematography and overall
atmosphere though this tale has been
told thousands of times over the
centuries it hasn't felt this original
for a while that's definitely no easy
task
a massively enjoyed Gretel and Hansel
and though the movie wasn't perfect I
definitely recommend that he give it a
shot
growling Hansel was great and it gets a
seven out of 10 now obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the movie and
what you took from the ending comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown of this weekend's big Netflix
release uncut gems which is going to be
linked at the end we give our thoughts
on the final few moments of the film so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below you get access to content
early and can also suggest video topics
and breakdowns you massively appreciate
it and it goes a long way to helping
videos like this get made if you want to
come chat to us after the show either
follow us a definition whitey or click
the discord link in the description
below every month we give away free
movies to people who are subscribed to
the channel and this one's he can win
dr. sleep and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of February so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe huge thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care
[Music]